I was looking at this film like wow this
is tiring watching it sometimes was it
was it physically demanding for you
that's different than being exhibited I
didn't all right each is a good thing
like I'm so tired yeah it was it was
really it was eat of the emotional
challenge of playing this character was
just as demanding and as the physical
challenge so it was it was a lot of work
yeah there's such a following for this
film and there was a little bit of
controversy in the beginning because all
the fans are like what do you mean she's
cast and this it's an anime you know
it's a Japanese movie why is she cast
what was your reaction to it did you
have any apprehension taking it on maybe
um well I you know I I was in the middle
of production and you know I was so deep
in the experience of this character that
living is very unique experience where
she is a human brain in an entirely
machine ate body and you know is on this
kind of universal quest for her own
identity on you know it was hard for me
to like I thought that's what my focus
was on not only creating a character
that was that was multi-dimensional and
you know i think the the original film
stands alone on its own so beautifully
it's so beautifully directed and it's
and and and really profound you know
just to kind of try to replace that film
you know or totally recreate it is it
he'd be up against so many kinds of you
know battles you can't win sure and the
suit i was just talking to Rupert he was
saying it wasn't real that suit that you
were wearing and the suits roll the
suits real yeah it's downstairs right
now actually I didn't anyone ever to
wear it again no God no yeah no I'm
never going to worry about God I know if
I ever were to get it have to be like
some different incarnation of the suit
no actually this it was fine i have like
a wetsuit I guess right and just
requires some more talcum powder and a
second person to put it on what's more
comfortable that one or the black widow
probably this this suit the major suit
and ghost in the shell is more
comfortable
put on okay it's just yeah it's actually
kind of like a second skin and so when
I'm being dragged all over the concrete
and like thrown around it sort of acted
like a protective layer okay most people
never have to think about it there you
go I recently signed interviewed with
you you're talking about the value of
being a working mom and I love that
because I'm working mom I'm a single mom
I would daughter and it's just very
empowering to hear you talk about that
does your daughter know yet what you do
like that mommy's an actress and the
genetics of this and he's kind of
figuring it out you know she's still
pretty little she's two and a half but
it's so like she'll notice me in a film
but then every other blonde person also
looks like me right now that's not
mamita wiinblad or whatever haha yeah I
think she you know she's starting to get
catch the drift now and a couple of
weeks ago I was really fortunate enough
to host SNL at this time and it was the
first time Wilson she was an infant the
first time she came to visit me on sex i
was still nursing or actually but then
this time you know she's really a you
know a young you know she's a toddler
and so she was able to totally take in
whatever he was doing in their
Department and walk around this historic
set and come down the stairs onto the
stage you know she was meeting all these
incredibly talented comedians and Lorne
Michaels and you know she was just like
so in it yeah it was really cool to be
able to share my job with her you know
it's it's it's really it's exciting for
me now my question to you is what's next
are you going to run for office because
you're so good at public speaking and
doing no kind of yeah did you ever
consider that um I don't know you know
it's just I think if I love you know I'd
love to be involved in local politics I
think local politics is were you know
the conversations start that's worrying
and the most change can can be affected
and you know I I wouldn't like not
consider a career in perhaps local
politics someday but I just right now
I'm so busy running around after her
yeah I reckon on that you know that's
totally where my brain is and I think
you know that I think politics is
something that requires like all of you
is everything even more so than most
other jobs you just responsible for like
other greater good about community of
people but I mean when I guess when she
grows up to you want her to know Mom as
being big Hollywood actress or a mom who
stands up to women's rights I think you
know those two things really are you
know two very important parts of the you
know the the the whole person you see in
front of you you know my I'm been
working for 20 years in the film
industry it's an industry that I that I
that has its own unique challenges but
that I love and I also you know I grew
up in a very politically active socially
active and very vocal family and that's
a huge part of also you know my the
person that I am today so I think
they're not there don't have to be
separate of one another one hand holds
the other there you go that's not a good
a fighter meeting you thank you thank
you